[Musique]
comment chasser les mauvaises herbes
sans herbicide des chercheurs américains
ont mis au point une technique originale
pour éliminer les mauvaises herbes dans
les champs il leur lance des projectiles
à l'aide d'un pulvérisateur à pression
il tire des coquilles de noix ou de la
farine de gluten sur les plantes
nuisibles
cela les tue ou les endommages assez
pour qu'elle meurent par la suite ce
concept appelé désherbage par abrasion
ou par projectile et vu comme une
solution de rechange à l'utilisation des
herbicides de ce côté-ci de la frontière
des chercheurs d'Agriculture et
Agroalimentaire Canada tentent
d'améliorer le concept ils utilisent une
sableuse commerciale reliée à un
compresseur d'air qui tire quelques
grammes de projectiles par mètre carré
en Ontario ce sont les champs de
haricots secs qui sont ciblés à l'île du
procédoir le désherbage par projectile
se fait dans les champs de pommes de
terre au Québec l’exercice se fait dans
des vignobles alors qu'en
Colombie-Britannique ça se passe dans
des champs de bleuets d'ici 2024
l'équipe canadienne de recherche espère
avoir trouvé le meilleur matériau pour
les projectiles
[Musique]